[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de parlement hebdo 26 minutes
pour parcourir l'actualité de
l'assemblée du sénat en votre compagnie
brigitte d'un jour dames bonjour
brigitte on va s'intéresser aux temps
forts de la semaine marquée par le début
de l'examen de la réforme des retraites
dans l'hémicycle de l'assemblée un débat
embourbé une ambiance électrique est
notre invité pour parler de tout ça est
aujourd'hui aurélien pradié bonjour
bonjour vous êtes député et l'air du lot
et brigitte à retrouver votre carte
d'identité
bonjour aurélien pradié vous êtes né à
cahors députés à 31 ans secrétaire
général du parti des républicains à 33
ans votre ascension est fulgurante
homme de droite vous êtes un amoureux de
jacques chirac avec qui vous partagez un
combat commun sur les questions de
handicap
vous avez aussi fait voter une
proposition de loi contre les violences
conjugales
très attaché à votre terroir vous vantez
lamic et le pastis de spécialités
lotoise met-elle brice de nice dès que
vous le pouvez vous filez au cap ferret
pour aller surfer le surf c'est ce qui
vous permet de rester un peu en
équilibre dans ce monde politique
c'est surtout ce qui me permet de me
confronter aux éléments et à me rappeler
à toute l'humilité qu'on peut avoir dans
dans ces situations allez on commence
avec les titres de cette émission est à
l'assemblée la gauche de la gauche joue
l'obstruction sur le projet de loi
retraites entre suspensions de séance et
rappels au règlement
le débat est enlisée il pourrait mener à
un 49 3 la cgt a quitté mardi la table
de la conférence de financement aucun
accord n'a été trouvé entre la cfdt et
le medef dont les positions s'éloigne
les syndicats contestent atteint
réfléchisse à une conférence parallèle
elisabeth bornes auditionné au sénat sur
l'avenir de la filière nucléaire alors
que fessenheim ferme son premier
réacteur
la ministre entend poursuivre le
développement ordonné de l'éolien et on
commence tout de suite avec la guérilla
parlementaire autour des retraites
[Musique]
le débat sur les retraites enlisé à
l'assemblée les insoumis et les
communistes multiplie les amendements et
des sous-amendements pour freiner la
discussion le patron des marcheurs
gilles legendre parle de sabotage
parlementaire une obstruction qui
pourrait mener à l'utilisation du 49-3
compte rendu des débats avec elsa
mandingue avant jeudi après midi richard
ferrand commence la séance par une mise
au point à ce rythme
mille six cent quarante trois heures de
séances seront nécessaires pour terminer
la seule loi ordinaire soit si
l'assemblée siège du lundi au dimanche
soir
en respectant les heures réglementaires
l'océan ce 150 jours de séance la veille
lors d'une séance particulièrement
houleuse les débats se sont même
interrompu en cause les règles fixées en
conférence des présidents sur la
suppression des amendements identiques
mais placés sur différents articles du
texte
la règle a changé que tous les collègues
comprennent n'a pas changé des centaines
de nos amendements vont tomber
on détourne complètement les débats avec
cette règle d'interprétation
les oppositions ont multiplié les
rappels au règlement merci monsieur le
président je veux pas répéter les
arguments sur lequel tombent dedans vous
le bon monsieur le président eh ben vous
allez le démontrer avant d'évoquer la
séance a été suspendue à de nombreuses
reprises la séance donc suspendu pour 15
minutes la séance suspendue pour cinq
minutes
jeudi le président de l'assemblée
richard ferrand est revenu sur sa
décision qu'on vient nous en sommes tous
d'accord qu aucun prétexte d'obstruction
ne subsiste ni le porte atteinte à la
dignité des débats dont les présidents
de séance sont les garants j'ai proposé
à la conférence des présidents que cette
règle ne soit pas appliquée pas de quoi
accélérer significativement les des bars
il reste plus de 35 mille amendements à
étudier les députés poursuivent donc
laborieusement l'examen de la réforme
des retraites sans savoir s'ils pourront
terminer un jour
aurélien pradié on a entendu richard
ferrand 150 heures de débat ça à peu
près cinq mois de discussions ici à
l'assemblée pour terminer ce projet de
loi sur les retraites on va forcément se
finir en 49 3 en vote bloqué ici à
l'assemblée
on sait depuis le début c'est une
évidence tout ça est une mise en scène
qui devient grotesque
si le gouvernement n'a fait que ni et
justice oui mais écoutez on voit la
ficelle est grosse comme comme ce n'est
pas imaginable
depuis le début il ya une complicité
claire qui s'était installé entre ceux
qui tentent l'obstruction la france
insoumise les communistes et le
gouvernement et la majorité qui
n'attendent que ça et voyez ce spectacle
délirant
j'ai passé des heures en séance on ne
traite pas du fond mais je les renvoyer
deux ados vous assure une condamnez pas
l'obstruction particulièrement c'était
de la fausse insoumise
si mais pas seulement aussi ce qui dans
ce bal d d d hypocrites sont totalement
complices de la situation
tout cela arrange le gouvernement tout
cela arrange la majorité parce que la
vérité c'est que il joue les clowns en
disant qu'ils veulent le débat ils ne
veulent pas le débat est donc il se
positionne en victime il se met dos au
mur et puis ils attendent patiemment que
que la machine puisse être bloquée pour
activer le 49-3 ce qui serait dramatique
puisque nous n'aurions pas pu examiner
le fond du sujet une dernière remarque
il se trouve qu'en commission spéciale
nous avons eu le même spectacle de
pîtres puisqu'en commission spéciale
nous n'avons pas pu aller au bout de
l'examen et que tout le travail qui
avait été fait est ordinairement est
tombée nous sommes revenus à 0 donc
c'est un vaste une vaste mais là ce
débat y sert à rien finalement
on n'arrive pas à aller sur le fond mais
c'est un échec de la méthode très au
delà de cet épisode là c'est aussi la
dictée la meet adou c'est aussi le fond
de la réforme pour vous les deux échecs
du gouvernement
les deux mais c'est d'abord l'échec de
cette méthode là le gouvernement et
emmanuel macron lorsqu'il a été élu
président de la république il ya
maintenant quelques années avait
théorisé la volonté de rassembler les
français la volonté de dialoguer avec
les uns et les autres et vous voyez le
niveau de blocage auxquelles nous en
sommes aujourd'hui
depuis le début le gouvernement joue les
gros bras sur ce texte là depuis le
début ils disent on passera en force
peu importe ce que disent les
partenaires sociaux peu importe ce que
pensent et français et peu importe ce
que pensent et parlementaires et bien
voilà dans un pays comme le nôtre lorsqu
on méprise la démocratie on la reprend
il ya quelque chose de boue quand même
dans cette réforme la démarche de la
réforme probablement mais moi je veux
être très précis je ce message il n'est
pas très clair celui de la droite vous
dites levé tâches à la fois la méthode
et ben laden peut être le mauvais tâche
et d'éclaircir mais la méthode en
politique ça veut dire quelque chose ça
veut dire le mépris ou le respect clown
à des concitoyens et la manière dont le
gouvernement a amené cette réforme est
la démonstration du mépris qu'ils ont de
nos concitoyens et des parlementaires
mais sur le fond sur le fond la droite
républicaine a toujours été opposée au
régime par points
ce régime par points et on le voit il
cristallise les débats c'est un régime
injuste c'est un régime instable
puisqu'on n'était pas contre un quand il
était le candidat de la droite
l'ordinateur via n'a pas toujours
incarner l'histoire de la droite
républicaine
aujourd'hui la position des républicains
et nous l'avons exprimée clairement
c'est d'être opposés au régime par
points parce qu'il nous paraît dangereux
et nous paraît être une porte
entrouverte vers un système égoïste
auquel nous ne nous n'aspirons pas et je
le redis la droite républicaine quand
elle a fondé le système des retraites à
l'après guerre était aussi le régime par
points mais au delà il y à une vaste
hypocrisie sur ce texte là nous sommes
favorables à la suppression des régimes
spéciaux il faut que les français
comprennent qu emmanuel macron
contrairement à ce qu'il dit n'a pas
l'intention de supprimer les régimes
spéciaux
la première suppression des régimes
spéciaux ne n'arrivera pas avant trois
ou quatre quinquennat à venir hilare
fabriquer des nouveaux régimes
particuliers pour notamment les
techniques mais on va quand même l'un de
ces régimes spéciaux est ce que 2 fait
vous ne pouvez pas ne pas voter cette
réforme ce que la droite républicaine
avait fait mais la question des régimes
spéciaux ne résume pas l'ensemble de
cette réforme des retraites nous sommes
opposés au système par points je le
disais tout à l'heure
et puis là où nous avons un point
d'opposition fondamentale c'est sur la
mesure d' équilibre budgétaire
ce que la droite dit c'est assez simple
nous pensons qu'il faut travailler
davantage et que c'est de cette manière
là qu'on pourra ré équilibrer le système
des retraites il faut avoir le courage
de le dire ce que nous avons aussi
proposé
c'est un système de pénibilité
universelle qui n'existe pas dans les
propositions dans le projet de loi du
gouvernement qui permet lorsque vous
avez travaillé cinq ans en situations de
pénibilité de gagner une année notre
discours il est très clair ayons le
courage de dire qu'il faut travailler
davantage
mais il ya aussi le courage de dire que
pour les métiers les plus pénibles y
compris nos infirmières nous aide
soignante et tant d'autres métiers nous
pourront partir plus tôt à la retraite
le gouvernement s'est planqué depuis le
début il louvoie sur ce texte là et on
arrive à ce résultat
rendez compte tout de même que nous
sommes en train de débattre ou de faire
semblant de débattre d'un texte pour
lequel nous n'avons pas le début du
commencement d'une solution de finances
mais vous finalement vous souhaiter le
retour de l'âge pivot qui pourrait
revenir finalement lors de cette
conférence à la joute niveau parce que
l'âge pivot c'est le comble de
l'hypocrisie dont je parlais là je puis
le 26 du mois du report de l'âge légal
de départ à la salle que vous réclamez
ci s'est éloigné parce que ce que nous
proposons c'est une mesure claire un
report de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite une possibilité de partir plus
tôt lorsque votre métier est pénible et
la garantie du même niveau des pensions
l'âge pivot ça veut dire quoi l'âge
pivot ça veut dire la baisse des
pensions
ça veut dire que vous partirez à l'âge
que vous souhaiterez avec une décote
très importantes sur les pensions la
droite nous pensons une considérant que
le niveau des pensions est fondamentale
préférant une mesure d'âge qui assurent
le niveau de pension pour tout le monde
a une mesure hypocrite comme celle de
l'âge pivot pipeau puisque c'est comme
ça qu'on l'appelle souvent juste un mot
sur encore la bataille un qui a lieu
dans l'hémicycle à ce que vous jugez
qu'au niveau de la communication si la
france insoumise qui a su tirer son
épingle du jeu
si la communication se résume à faire du
bruit à faire du brouhaha willy l'on
sait c'est important inaudible dans cet
hémicycle la communication c'est
peut-être important le brouhaha ça l'est
un peu moins
c'est un rendez-vous de crédibilité pour
la droite républicaine vous n'arrivez
pas tellement vous faire entendre quand
même dans l'hémicycle oui mais c'est pas
notre sujet notre sujet c'est d'être
crédible c'est d'être sérieux pourquoi
parce que à la différence de la france
insoumise nous aspirons à diriger ce
pays et ce que nous voulons c'est parce
que les arguments dans l'hémicycle vous
ne pouvez pas avec cette bataille
objectivement que depuis plusieurs mois
la droite ne s'est pas égaré sur ce
sujet que nous avons eu un discours
crédible peut-être est-ce pour ça qu'il
est plus difficile à entendre mais la
responsabilité de la droite républicaine
c'est pas de faire du bruit c'est pas de
jouer la comédie c'est pas de se résumer
à des pitres dans l'hémicycle c'est
d'être sérieux et nous avons donc eu une
position sérieuse depuis le début de
cette réforme elle est aurélien pradié
on continue à parler des retraites
puisque on poursuit cette émission avec
le financement du projet de loi
[Musique]
oui la conférence de financement qui a
commencé ses travaux ce mardi la cgt
menacent déjà de claquer la porte et
propose une contre conférence
de leur côté la cfdt et le medef
affichent des positions irréconciliables
l amont d'un gars va en parallèle du
débat parlementaire
la conférence de financement autour de
la table les partenaires sociaux chargés
de faire des propositions pour combler
le déficit du système des retraites
estimé à 12 milliards d'euros pour 2027
mardi une réunion s'est tenue au
ministère de la santé mais le ton est
monté
la cgt a un ton annoncé claqué la porte
avant de poser un ultimatum au
gouvernement
la balle est dans le camp du
gouvernement en gouvernement doit faire
des choix soit il donne raison mais 9
soit il écoute les syndicats le medef
insiste en effet sur la nécessité d'une
mesure d'âge quand d'autres syndicats
proposent tôt une hausse des cotisations
un dialogue de sourds alors que le
gouvernement menace de reprendre la main
si les syndicats ne s'entendent pas sur
une feuille de route commune
un prochain rendez vous est prévu début
mars et les conclusions attendues pour
fin avril théoriquement après la
première lecture de la réforme des
retraites à l'assemblée un calendrier
que dénoncent les oppositions aurélien
pradié la cgt sur le point de claquer la
porte on voit que force ouvrière et la
cfdt et le medef n'arrivent pas à se
mettre d'accord et semble avoir des
positions qui s'éloigne de plus en plus
est est ce qu'on peut parvenir à un
accord lors de cette conférence de
financement pas comme ça d'abord le vrai
problème c'est quelle mission on donne
la conférence de financement et c'est là
le vrai poison de cette méthode là la
vérité c'est que le gouvernement pour se
sortir de la nasse à tenter cette
réforme avec une conférence de
financement dans la précipitation
copé jean bergé qui l'avait proposée oui
c'est bien sûr pour tenter de sortir de
la situation dans la plupart ne m'en
voulez pas ils ont proposé à cette
conférence de décidé d' acte majeur qui
devrait être décidé au parlement qui le
mode de financement
du système et puis les partenaires
sociaux sont pas d'accord au fond on va
sortir quoi de cette conférence de
finalement si on en sort quelque chose
on va sortir deux mesures possibles
la baisse du niveau des pensions puisque
c'est la solution pour financer le
système
ou alors le hausse des cotisations
exigées par le gouvernement associations
2.6 le dimanche dernier mais si le
gouvernement réunit les partenaires
sociaux en excluant de la possibilité de
négocier ce que les partenaires sociaux
ont en tête vous voyez bien en fait la
vérité tout ça c'est que c'est voué à
l'échec depuis le début en tout cas cela
montre une chose c'est que ça servait à
rien d'attendre la fin des conclusions
de la conférence de financement pour
faire le débat parlementaire puisque
vous le dites vous-même la conférence de
financement elle est vouée à l'échec
c'est mal barré a dit le président de la
commission des affaires sociales au
sénat alain milon
oui si ça serve à quelque chose amuser
la galerie à gagner un peu de temps à
distraire les uns et les autres a essayé
d'éteindre la mobilisation sociale
c'est juste ça c'est de la pure tactique
et moi je trouve que la ficelle est
tellement grosse que je trouve ça
absolument fou que les partenaires
sociaux soient tombés dans le panneau et
la situation dans laquelle nous sommes
là où nous l'attendions depuis le début
je leur dis tout ça c'est un bal des
hypocrites et je le dis à la cgt la cgt
joue les idiots utiles du gouvernement
emmanuel macron adore avoir les énervés
de la clcv dire que le gouvernement
aurait dû faire sans les partenaires
sociaux non mais ils auraient dû faire
ce que l'on fait quand on réformer un
système des retraites de manière aussi
aussi importante discuter d'abord avec
les parlementaires prendre le temps de
la discussion
accepter de ne pas imposer aux français
ce qu'ils ne souhaitent pas avoir le
temps du dialogue est désormais demi de
concertation en vente il vous faire
valoir ce qu'a fait jean paul delevoye
et on voit la situation n'est pas du
tout réglé pour autant
oui mais enfin écoutez moi je ne sais
pas ce que jean-paul delevoye a fait
pendant deux ans et demi nos à
l'assemblée nationale on n'a pas
beaucoup entendu sur ce sujet les
derniers les premières simulations nous
les avons eus avec la fameuse étude
d'impact qui d'ailleurs largement pipés
nous l'avons eu quelques jours avant le
débat le début des débats parlementaires
durant ces deux années
ils ont pas concertés je leur dis ils
ont amusé la galerie ils ont fait
mousser les uns les autres ils ont
rencontré pour le plaisir de rencontrer
sans aucune volonté d'avancer je fais
une remarque sur la gouvernance de la
réforme sur le pilotage la réforme là
quand même un petit sujet vous le disiez
jean paul delevoye était aux manettes au
début
de la réforme il a été sorti
précipitamment du gouvernement c'est
agnès buzyn qui en ministre de tutelle
devait piloter le dispositif
elle a été sortie précipitamment pour
aller à la bataille partisane de paris
et aujourd'hui on a un ministre monsieur
virant qui n'a pas si j'ai encore une
seule fois au banc il ya un vrai
problème de pilotage politique à venir
c'est leurs emplettes rashevski qui a
repris le dossier et olivier ferrand il
semble faire la faire ses premières
prises de parole je vous sais qu'ici en
tant que ministre enfin non enfin ont
été à la hauteur oui il a pas dit trop
de conneries depuis le début sa prise de
fonction c'est ce que vous voulez dire
il y en a quelques-unes néanmoins mais
c'est pas comme ça que je juge les
choses et j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
le secrétaire d'état qui s'occupe de ce
sujet et je dis juste que les
secrétaires d'état ils ont ministre de
tutelle et c'est pas irrespectueux de le
dire c'est la vérité d'organisation du
gouvernement est que depuis le départ on
devrait avoir un ministre de tutelle m
poids politique qui donne un sens
politique à une réforme des retraites
sens politique avec une majuscule et ils
fonctionnent comme des contrôleurs de
gestion
vous savez depuis le début on nous avait
promis un gouvernement de deux
performeurs gouvernement de spécialistes
et on a un gouvernement de bricoleur
d'amateurs un terme assumer par emmanuel
macron oui mais la raison quand on a un
gros défaut il vaut mieux l'assumer il
peut assumer d'être amateur si ça si ça
lui fait plaisir
non je pense que ce sont des bricoleurs
véritablement des bricoleurs et ceux qui
ne sont pas bricoleur sont cyniques ya
un problème de constate départ quand
même sur cette conférence de financement
et sur le financement de la réforme est
d'ailleurs laurent berger dit que c'est
pas la priorité
est ce qu'il ya une urgence est-ce qu'il
faut absolument trouver ces 12 milliards
d'ici 2027
ou pas et maintenant on nous sort un
document en disant que le déficit cumulé
entre 2018 et 2030 pourrait atteindre
113 milliards d'euros c'est à n'y rien
comprendre finalement oui et c'est
d'ailleurs le fond du sujet sur la
question du financement même dispositif
la vérité si on regarde objectivement
c'est que dans les quelques années qui
viennent on a pas de sujets urgents de
financement du système des retraites
qu'en revanche sur plusieurs décennies
quand tu notamment notre démographie le
système doit évoluer
ça c'est quelque chose que l'on peut
dire de manière sérieuse ce qui veut
donc dire que l'on aurait pu profiter
des quelques années que nous avons
devant nous pour approfondir cette
réforme là pour ensuite passer à nous
au système mais vous savez si on va
politiquement au fond des choses
emmanuel macron a fait de cette réforme
là un totem pourquoi parce que depuis le
début il perçoit bien que les français
ont un doute sur ses capacités de
réformateurs depuis le début de son
mandat emmanuel macron fait le crocodile
et les grandes bouches et puis des
petits bras il parle beaucoup il
revendique de grandes réformes et les
français progressivement se rend compte
que tout ça c'est une vaste comédie et
donc il a préempté la question des
réformes des retraites pour essayer de
se sauver politiquement et c'est là en
fait tout le drame c'est qu'on ne se
sauve pas politiquement avec une réforme
des retraites on porte une réforme des
retraites pour sauver le système pour
répondre aux attentes des français
pas pour se sauver politique trop tard
dans le quinquennat oui elle arrive trop
tard ou trop tôt j'en sais rien en tous
les cas la méthode n'est pas la bonne
emmanuel macron en réformant la retraite
ne cherche qu'à se sauver politiquement
alors qu'il devrait vouloir servir
l'intérêt général est les derniers
thèmes dans cette émission la mise à
l'arrêt de la centrale de fessenheim
[Musique]
arrêts du premier réacteur ce week-end
fermeture définitive au mois de juin
pour la plus vieille centrale nucléaire
française elisabeth borna ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire était
auditionné au sénat cette semaine elle a
réaffirmé ses objectifs et dénoncé le
développement anarchique des éoliennes
aux rêves états un premier acte les
prochaines fermetures devraient
intervenir en 2025
car d'ici 2035 quatorze des 58 réacteurs
du parc français actuels doivent cesser
de fonctionner si les objectifs sont
tenues le nucléaire ne représentera plus
que 50% de la part des énergies
produites dans le pays
oui mais voilà il faut développer et
drastiquement celles dites renouvelables
et sur ce sujet les sénateurs avaient
beaucoup de questions dans les trois
heures qui viennent jouer les forces et
de répondre à vos questions sur l'éolien
notamment des parcs éoliens c'est bien
des forêt d'éoliennes
c'est pas bon du tout dans le paysage en
réponse elisabeth borgne a critiqué
sévèrement le développement anarchique
des installations une première pour une
ministre de l'écologie
d'autant que le gouvernement a jusqu'ici
beaucoup défendu la filière éolienne
il ya vraiment à la fois des
implantations de parcs éoliens au co
visibilité avec des monuments
historiques
je comprends même pas comment on a pu
arriver à ces situations on a des
territoires dans lesquels on a une
dispersion de petits parcs de taille de
forme variable qui donne une saturation
visuels en est en train de travailler
avec les élus concernés pour changer les
règles pour s'assurer que on arrive à
définir des zones propices et d'autres
qui ne le sont pas plus d'harmonie donc
car il n'est pas question de diminuer la
place des éoliennes au contraire
le parc devrait passer de 8000 à 14 1500
mah en france d'ici 2028
aurélien pradié on va parler des
éoliennes mais d'abord est ce que vous
êtes vous favorable à la fermeture de la
centrale de fessenheim
non parce que là encore c'est un totem
politique fessenheim il faut rappeler ce
dont nous parlons c'est quarante années
de production c'est une de nos centrales
les plus sécurisés les rapports
d'inspection sont très claires de ce
point de vue c'est un fleuron industriel
c'est aussi la plus vieille centrale
française oui mais c'est la plus
sécurisée sur laquelle il ya eu beaucoup
de niveau était une claire a quand même
mis en garde sur des défauts non sur le
niveau de sécurité globale de la
centrale on n'a véritablement pas de
sujet je le lis très très sereinement
au delà c'est un fleuron industriel
c'est une fierté
le nucléaire civil dans notre pays
l'année dernière fessenheim ces 12
milliards de kilowatt heure produit est
un vrai savoir faire industriel et au
fond cette fermeture là elle n'est
d'ailleurs que très peu assumée par
emmanuel macron il faut se souvenir d'où
vient un engagement de la fermeture
il vient d'un accord politique
électorale entre françois hollande et
les écologistes en 2012 et emmanuel
macron n'a fait que proroger sept
accords politiciens disait aussi il
aurait pu il aurait pu revenir dessus en
effet mais il n'a pas eu le courage de
le faire mais au fond parce que je dis
simplement c'est que d'abord c'est un
drame pour le territoire il faut
comprendre l'impact très fort que cela
va avoir pour l'alsace et on peut pas
négliger l'impact pour les alsaciens est
ce que je veux dire aussi c'est que
c'est révélateur du fait que notre pays
a abandonné ce qui faisait son fleuron
industriel et le nucléaire civil est un
fleuron industriel
on ne croit plus en la capacité de
production de notre pays quand on voit
par exemple le problème que pose
l'enfouissement des déchets nucléaires
est-ce que l'on peut laisser cet
héritage là aux générations futures
on peut aussi faire de la recherche
quand on lance le grand programme
messmer en 1974 sur le nucléaire
la france croit en sa capacité à régler
ces problèmes là en développer du
nucléaire dont on sait aujourd'hui qu'il
a une très faible impact sur le co2
notamment et à chercher des solutions on
peut toujours innover le programme
astrid d'un programme de recherche sur
le nucléaire civil a été abandonné par
la france
on a baissé les armes on considère
aujourd'hui qu'on ne peut pas mieux
faire
la question du traitement des déchets
radioactifs est un vrai sujet il faut
que notre nation notre pays y compris
avec des partenaires européens soient
capables de réfléchir à ce sujet là de
trouver des nouvelles propositions de
recherche et d'innovation qu'il ya la
cap 21 qui a fixé un certain nombre
d'objectifs dont celui de réduire à 50%
la part de
nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité d'ici 2035 est ce que vous
vous partager cet objectif avec le
gouvernement aujourd'hui il faut que
nous soyons très précises sur ce sujet
la fermeture du réacteur de fessenheim
va avoir quelques conséquences
immédiates de renforcer la production
d'une de nos centrales à charbon c'est
la vérité puisque l'on consomme toujours
autant d'électricité et donc lorsqu'on
ferme dispositif de nucléaire civil
alors on fait produire plus par une
centrale à charbon temporaire pour lui
les quatre centrales à charbon vont
fermer sous 7 juil mais sauf que on sait
parfaitement que sous cette législature
on ne pourra pas et fermer les centrales
nucléaires et fermer les centrales à
charbon on n'a pas douté mais le rôle
est d'être aussi pris part les énergies
renouvelables qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
que vous en pensez d'ailleurs à un mois
sur le fait que la ministre a dénoncé le
développement anarchique des éoliennes à
la raison est la raison nous avons des
territoires qui aujourd'hui ont été
massacrés par les dispositifs éolien ce
que je sais simplement c'est que c'est
un bobard de dire à nos concitoyens
aujourd'hui qu'on va pouvoir faire mais
le nucléaire fermer les centrales à
charbon et les remplacer par des
éoliennes alors même qu'on sait que le
développement anarchique des éoliennes
sur notre territoire pose un problème
vous demander un moratoire justement sur
l'installation d'éoliennes
je pense que nous avons un vrai sujet
sur leur niveau de développement la
ministre a raison de dire qu'il ya des
situations dans lesquelles c'est tout à
fait invraisemblable on a planté des
éoliennes à quelques centaines de mètres
de monuments historiques
il faut aussi pardon de le dire que les
préfectures fassent leur boulot en
contrôlant les choses il faut sûrement
que le lobby qui est plus important pour
les éoliennes parfois même que pour le
nucléaire baisse d'un ton et laisse les
parlementaires faire le boulot comme ils
doivent le faire
bref il faut juste que nous nous
reposions sur ce sujet moi je suis pas
un ayatollah du nucléaire se dit le
renouvelable quand même prennent le
relais des audiences sur le solaire
notamment évidemment mais on ne peut pas
faire n'importe quoi
au prétexte de vouloir passer d'une
énergie à une autre je le redis je ne
suis pas un ayatollah du nucléaire je
dis juste que nous devrions pouvoir
investir plus de recherches pour faire
mieux en matière nucléaire et ne pas
abandonner cette force de production
nationale rien prédire vous avez
commencé à en parler à l'impact sur le
tissu économique local de la fermeture
totale de fessenheim ce sujet a fait
réagir le député les républicains
raphaël challenger également président
de la commission de la mission
d'information sur la fermeture de cette
centrale en l'écoutant
aujourd'hui l'inquiétude et le porte
sur deux sujets l'avenir du territoire
sa situation économique sa situation
sociale parce qu'aujourd'hui rien
absolument rien n'est fait ou soutenues
par le gouvernement pour antipuces
anticipé cette situation
et puis d'autre part une question
grandissante celle de
l'approvisionnement de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement électrique façon
plus large à l'échelle de la plaque du
rhin supérieur en europe parce que des
rapports sont en train de sortir du côté
allemand sur des risques à partir de
2023 sur la qualité de
l'approvisionnement
et puis en france où on fait la sourde
oreille alors on entend les oppositions
de votre collègue l'état lui dit qu'il a
correctement mené à la transition
économique a notamment un projet qui
s'appelle et chorena qui doit prendre la
suite est-ce que c'est à la hauteur non
tout ça a été fait dans la plus grande
des précipitations
parce qu'il me fera beaucoup c'est que
nous ne croyons plus en l'avenir de
notre pays
croyons plus en la force de la france
ait compris la force industrielle de la
france et l'état aujourd'hui accompagne
l'affaiblissement de la force
industrielle de notre nation moi je suis
un député les républicains mon collègue
raphaël jeune berger elle est aussi nous
croyons en l'avenir de la france en sa
capacité de produire et de s'affirmer
dans le pays et cet épisode de
fessenheim est assez révélateur du fait
qu'on soit parade passé de la croyance
en l'avenir de la nation à l'inquiétude
permanente moi je veux lutter contre l'
inquiétude et ce sont 2000 emplois qui
seraient menacés sur ce site merci
aurélien ce raid est d'avoir été avec
nous cette semaine merci tamer ce merci
à vous tous de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de parlement hebdo et
nous recevrons philippe barde le
sénateur merci à vous tous de nous avoir
suivi
[Musique]